we are alone more alone than we have
ever been and we feel isolated
be brave put kids first send our kids
back to schools
full time soon all this talk about
mental health is nothing more than hot
air unless we act accordingly
tonight many ccsd students and their
families say
enough is enough when it comes to
distance learning thank you for joining
us at 11 i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez earlier hundreds held a protest
ahead of the district's first
in-person board meeting in nearly a year
then parents and students
stood up during public comment to share
their struggles and
ask district leaders to take action and
open all the schools now
sasha loftis attended tonight's meeting
spoke with family she joins us downtown
with the very latest
sasha denise and brian those hundreds of
students and parents gathered outside
the las vegas academy of the arts today
to tell ccsd leaders they are still not
happy
this was the first time they were able
to address address trustees and the
superintendent in about a year
in person and they made it clear they
are struggling
we are kids living through a global
pandemic trying to pass our ap
exams and watching our friends die and
we are alone ccsd students
say they've had enough i'm failing all
my classes
i haven't learned anything they may
never recover they stood with hundreds
of parents protesting thursday
to share their frustration with clark
county school district leaders
you guys had all this time you know what
i mean all of this time to really like
give us a cool plan
this all happened during the first
in-person board meeting in about a year
and it comes just a day after leaders
announced a long-awaited plan to start
hybrid learning for most grades by
mid-march
and bring pre-k through five students
back full time by april
6. we feel that this point in time we
should be back full-time
not just hybrid model but families want
schools open now
they say the district is simply taking
too long
and for many the damage is already done
i open my laptop
i wake up in an empty room and i'm all
by myself
day after day like it's been since last
march they're asking for time to heal
from months of isolation
and uncertainty while learning together
safely
these kids they just deserve better